welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for stranger things season four
where the children of hawkins are
haunted by a ticking representation of
how their own youth has been awkwardly
drained from them over four seasons of
streaming content from vecna to changing
graves to a secret number code hidden in
one frame of this trailer i'm gonna
break this down frame by frame for
everything you might have missed let's
go
you've broken
everything
your suffering
is almost
so we start with the wreckage of the
machine under the star court mall from
season three after it exploded in a
blast that seemingly killed hopper but
the mid-credit scene revealed him alive
in russia suggesting he actually went
through that rift a rift that
interestingly opens on the other end to
russia some thoughts on that later a
transference seemingly confirmed in this
shot by that rift still glowing as if it
isn't yet all the way closed the opening
sound of this trailer actually sounds
kind of like an evil cackle
but it also sounds like the 80s horror
synth percussion that was popularized by
john carpenter's instrumentation in the
halloween movies you know like that
[Laughter]
but the voice we hear is that of the
villain of the season whose eyes flash
in this section in whose full form we
see at the end of the trailer this is
vecna keeping in with the tradition of
the demogorgon and the mind player vecna
is another character from dungeons and
dragons but is not based on any
mythological origin but rather a truly
original character from gary gygax's
greyhawk campaign setting the dnd becna
is an anagram for vance as in jack vance
author of the dying earth which inspired
the early feel of dnd magma really began
as a set of cursed artifacts a severed
hand and a gouged-out eye that over time
kind of evolved into his own character
and one of the more popular villains
from the early dnd settings a wizard
turned lich turned demigod by the way a
lich is a wizard who embraces undeath to
cling to the mortal world often take in
the form of a got skeletal humanoid with
skin stretched tight over its bones
vector's voice croaks you've broken
everything your suffering is almost at
an end so based on the editing at least
zecna might be associated with this
ticking grandfather clock that has
returned in every trailer for this the
duffer brothers said in their trailer
commentary on ign that this clock is a
very very important clue very important
to the story that they didn't want to
give away yet i'm thinking the
grandfather claw could be a kind of omen
that presents itself to you as a way of
vectors saying that your time is up and
he's coming to claim you though it
sounds like this season is going to show
us the origin of the upside down maybe
vecna is the super ego who lords over it
all i just find it interestingly ironic
that all these villains take the form of
d d characters almost as if they were
burst from the mind of an in-universe d
d nerd as if it's the imagination of
some kid rolling a 20-sided dice who's
bringing these things to life here a
close-up shows the beckman's eyes
opening blue the devil brothers said
this practical makeup was done by barry
gower who also did the prosthetics for
the blue-eyed night king of game of
thrones and the radiation victims of
chernobyl in that it was really
important for them for their boogeyman
to be practical to evoke horror villains
like freddy krueger and pinhead freddie
especially known for calling out from
alternate dimensions the way becna now
does on to the next clip dear billy
i don't know if you can even hear this
ever since you left everything's been
a total disaster so max reads a letter
to her brother billy who died after
being possessed by the mind player last
season this trailer opens with a reading
of a letter to a deceased character
season three ended with the reading of a
letter from a seemingly deceased
character we get a little nodded upside
down with this upside down shot of a
crime scene with hawkins locals
gathering to look as a body bag is
carted away this season the group is
split up the buyer's family joyce
jonathan will relocated to california
with 11 while the rest mike dustin lucas
steve robin nancy max and erica stayed
behind in hawkins mike will at one point
visit 11 in california probably on a
spring break trip meanwhile of course
hopper over in russia on to the next
clip for a while we tried to be happy
normal
i know that's impossible so we see how
lucas has joined the basketball team
leaving mike and dustin plumly
applauding for the bleachers as their
friend moves up the social ladder
without them now there are some posters
celebrating the seniors as class of 86
dating this series in spring 1986 and i
will just note that the chernobyl
disaster happened in april 1986 and the
duffers said they shot the russian
exteriors in lithuania deliberately to
evoke chernobyl which technically
chernobyl was in modern day ukraine and
hopefully it stays modern-day ukraine
but still with the makeup that is twice
that in their commentary they reference
chernobyl and i have theorized in the
past that the origin of the upside down
could have been one of the past covered
up soviet nuclear disasters that led up
to chernobyl one that historically we
still do not know about mike wears his
hellfire club shirt the hellfire club
being the name of his dmd group from
season one named after the mutant group
from the x-men comics and now we see the
series newcomer and major d d nerd eddie
munson wearing the same shirt later this
trailer eleven and will attend lenoir
hills high school in california lenora
hills being a fictional town looks like
will did a project on alan turing father
of computer science i don't mean to read
too much into this but with some
interpretations of will in season 3
speculating he might be gay alan turing
was cruelly forced to stay in the closet
with his accomplishments and computing
not credited to him you could imagine
this being something will might be able
to identify with but whatever his
orientation it's fine by me i don't want
to force this character in anything you
do you will and then we see the
grandfather clock presenting itself to
max wedged into a school wall possibly
an indicator that the vector has
targeted her and we do see her floating
above the grave site later but i got
more to say about that let's move on he
shots at the prison labor camp in
kamchatcha where hopper is kept walking
down those train tracks we saw him
working on in the from russia with love
teaser all the way back in february
2020.
remember that the before times the music
throughout this trailer is journey's
separate ways the editing here synced to
steve perry's vocals as he sings were
the part hearts broken into
two
reflecting how all of these characters
once united are now worlds apart
geographically worlds and in some cases
dimensional worlds mike visits with 11
and will in california holding 11's hand
at the roller rink and will looking at
mike ain't too happy about it well
whatever it is you do you moving on
because i thought you'd be safe
i'm afraid your friends and hawkins are
very much in the eye of the storm we
hear the voice of dr sam owens the great
paul reiser returning from season two
and we later see he is talking with
eleven in a diner but the dumper is
saying in addition to obviously wanting
to reference ryzer as bishop and aliens
they also wanted to nod to his role in
the 1982 film diner joyce receives a
package with a ton of stamps from the
ussr i don't think hopper would be in a
position to send her this kind of mail
but i do think this may have been sent
to her by murray baumann whom we last
heard his outgoing voicemail message
from a number teased by the show social
media telling joyce said he found
something interesting i'm guessing that
interesting thing is hopper still alive
meanwhile the hawkins kids visit the
creel house home of victor creel a guy
who murdered his family in the 50s the
80s version played by freddy krueger
actor himself the legendary robert
englund but his younger self played by
kevin l johnson aka sam from ozark
because netflix loves to reuse its
actors an overhead shot shows the light
bulb above their heads glowing brighter
evoking that light bulb over will in the
opening scene of the pilot episode when
the demogorgon took him nearby you can
see some candles suggesting other kids
over the years might have conducted
seances in this haunted house on to the
next clip i don't have my powers i don't
know how to say this other than just to
say it without you
we can't win this war okay 11 reminds us
that she no longer has her powers which
she lost in their final battle against
the mind player last season but the war
dr owens is referring to might just be
the cold war which did heat back up in
the 80s and i've always thought that
11's government experiments might have
just been an american countermeasure to
build up these psychic super soldiers to
combat soviet bioweapons aka the
demogorgon and the demo dogs and now it
looks like the demo bats of this season
it looks like eleven is being detained
and forced back into the front lines of
whatever that fight was but the craziest
detail of this trailer comes at one
minute and 59 seconds you gotta pause it
at the exact frame where it reveals this
trippy image that looks kind of like
acid washed film but with lightning
streaking through it with a series of
these burn spots looking almost like
white portals and beside each is a
numerical time code 146 230 033 and 052
okay the game is afoot okay this could
mean all kinds of things but right now i
think this applies to time codes in this
trailer at 146 we see mike watching 11
get driven away at 2 30 we see the d d
nerd eddie munson greeting us at 0-33
that was the shot of billy's gravestone
and then 052 that was the shot of dustin
and mike at the game but if you
superimpose the acid wash frame over
each of the corresponding shots the
white portals line up with letters on
signs and shirts in those particular
frames so if you go chronologically
through this trailer at 33 seconds the
one with three white portals those line
up with the letters i a and m on billy's
gravestone and then 052 the portal lines
up with hell on mike's shirt at 146 that
tiny little portal lines up with h and i
of lenora hills and 230 lines up with
master of the dungeon master screen
flyer so if i'm right about this all
together chronologically the frame would
spell out i am hell hi master or if we
were to go left to right top to bottom
regardless of the order of these showing
up in the trailer the phrase would be hi
i am master hell either way i am feeling
like this is not [ __ ] with us and i
am freaking out now i'll be honest with
you the way i put these connections
together is just staring at the screen
for a long time and if you're like me
and if you spend days staring at screens
you might notice some sore eyes and
problems sleeping turns out blue light
damages our eyes and leads to digital
eye strain the symptoms of which include
blurred vision headaches dry watery eyes
for some folks it can even affect your
energy level well blue blocks was
created to fix this problem and block
out the blue light with high quality
lenses thanks to blue blocks for
sponsoring this video blue blocks are
evidence-backed and made under optics
laboratory conditions in australia so
when i'm spending time in fluorescent
lighting staring at screens these
glasses are a big help they have over 40
styles of frames and come in
prescription non-prescription and
readers blue blocks also has other
amazing products such as low blue light
bulbs red light therapy devices and
sleep masks that i'm a huge fan of they
ship worldwide in a rapid time to make
returns and exchanges easy so go to
blueblocks.com new rockstars and use
coupon code new rockstars to save twenty
percent that's blueblox.com
b-l-u-b-l-o-x dot com slash new
rockstars and use a coupon code new
rockstars to save 20 and thanks again to
blue ox for sponsoring this video so
here demo bats swoop in toward that
creel house in the upside down maybe we
do see some red lightning strikes and
you can see there are dozens more of
these demo bats swarming over it now
when you look closely at these bats i
just love how they don't seem to have
any legs or claws just kind of these
droopy tendrils hanging down almost like
anatomically or biologically these are
not meant to ever land or roost anywhere
but rather much like the face hugger of
alien latch onto things with their
mouths if you think about it with the
original demogorgon matching the bipedal
xenomorph and the demo dogs in season 2
matching the quadrupedal xenomorph dog
in aliens 3 i just love how the
evolution of these things mirrors the
alien franchise also in that lightning
strike you can see that the creel house
is right across the street from a
playground casting it is a kind of
creepy specter that the kids of hawkins
would have exchanged urban legends about
then shot of steve and nancy pulling on
a tied bed sheet that probably dangles
from a portal above them steve wears a
jean vest with the pin for the 80s metal
band wasp but i really want to know
what's going on with his chest there's
like a darker region that could be a
tattoo or like that chess carpet matches
the trace or maybe some kind of rot or
mold like something that might allow him
to breathe in the upside down i don't
know behind them are some vines snaking
all over the wall suggesting that they
might already be in the upside down or
the upside down might have spread out to
terraform this side of hawkins i have a
theory about what these things are that
we'll get to at the end of the video it
looks like they are in or around that
vine colored forest hills trailer park
that eddie mike nancy and steve paddle
into we see hopper in russia a gas mask
strapped on just like he had to suit up
before venturing in the upside down and
hawkins season one to me confirming that
russia must have their own back door
into the upside down and that's how he
got there and that they might have been
using that connection to unleash
demogorgons into the american heartland
but back in the ussr it looks like they
are now testing the demogorgon in a
freaking gladiator arena with these poor
other prisoners now this demogorgon
looks smaller than one from season one
so maybe it's younger but i assume that
hopper's not gonna die in this death pit
he's probably gonna defeat it which
might be the soviet's way of making
stronger and stronger demo weapons kind
of like syndrome and incredibles testing
deadly and deadlier chronos's against mr
incredible and yeah this mythology does
make david harbor my thick daddy so
you're welcome then eddie munson dungeon
master greets us in his hellfire club
shirt ozzy osbourne hair love this guy
looks like he's set up by saint basil's
cathedral standing behind him the
landmark from moscow just another
interesting russia connection also
behind him are a bunch of d d and
cosplay outfits hung up like i mentioned
before i just think it's possible that
the upside down d d demonic figures in
it all this tied in with russia this
just might all be projections coming
from eddie's imagination maybe this guy
was one of the other previous numbers
from 11's testing program he could have
been number one and that when these
psychic kids got connected to the upside
down all of his nerdy fantasies
populated the dimension on to the next
clip people say hawkins is cursed
they're not
way off
[Music]
whoa so this season will flash back to
11th time when she was younger in the
hawkins lab perhaps de-aging millie
bobby brown as you see in the rainbow
room from the earlier teaser there is a
rift on the wall in the mirror there
blood all over her gown pouring from her
eyes the duffers confirmed that we will
learn what happened to the other numbers
we met eight in season two but there's a
whole bunch of other numbers in that
lineup maybe even ones after eleven but
they also said this shot of eleven
screaming soldiers blasting off her this
is not a flashback so she's gonna end up
getting her head shaped and she's gonna
have to go back into that psychic child
soldier mode i'm wondering if these guys
are russians as she is now rescuing
hopper from that facility there's one
shot of erica in this trailer in the
creel house using what looks like a bug
zapper as a lantern then there's a shot
of steve swimming up to an underwater
rift this might be the quarry from
season one actually later we see him
bursting up out of the other side of
that portal tethered so this underwater
portal burps up into open air on the
other side one of the stranger shots in
this trailer is max floating above the
gravesite over lucas steve and dustin
obviously this is gonna be a big season
for max i'm guessing she's gonna be a
major target of the vacna but look at
billy's gravestone before it's at billy
hargrove now it says william hargrove
the birth and the death dates and the
epitaph are all the same so i don't know
if this was a production error or if
this headstone might get destroyed and
then replaced at some point and they
either shortened or lengthened billy's
name actually later we see max fleeing a
red tinted hellscape toward a portal in
the distance that looks like and that
portal has three figures peering out at
her probably lucas steve and dustin this
could be what that possession looks like
from her point of view when she's
trapped in this other dimension trying
to sprint back to her three friends on
the other side but we see in the
foreground chasing after her looks like
the clawed hand of the vecna there then
another shot of steve batting down a
demo bat with an ore as eddie rocks out
with his guitar on the trailer roof what
the hell is this mad max fury road [ __ ]
and why do i love it so much i wondered
if they could have set up this amp at a
specific frequency to attract all the
bats away from someplace else like the
krill house and eddie is just enjoying
it way too much then this awesome shot
of robert england as victor creel his
eyes are scarred shut which might
connect him to the vekna who according
to d d mythology started as just a hand
in a gouged-out eye i don't know maybe
like the mummy or something the vecna is
now harvesting body parts from various
different hosts like victor and max and
others all to sustain himself and stay
alive then this crazy shot of joyce and
murray crashing a propeller plane in a
frozen forest looks like we're gonna see
some kind of rescue mission to free
hopper then on to the last section
you
have lost
oh man so again the demo bats circle the
creel house and then we get the glory
shot of the vecna and again those
prosthetics were all practical except
according to the duffers those tendrils
that stick out of his back and lower him
down from the rafters so i may be
mistaken but i'm pretty sure that those
tendrils are actually all of those vines
that we have seen snaking everywhere
across the backgrounds that the upside
downs of vegetative outgrowth might be
hive extensions of this carnivorous
predator in this case the vechna lich
using these appendages to feed himself
from miles and miles away perhaps the
entire upside down could be an outgrowth
of a singular entity back now the entire
dimension feeding back to the source we
may learn folks that the upside down is
not a place it's a vector let me know
your favorite part from this trailer and
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos following the rockstars and
subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you